>> Joey: THE WORLD'S BIGGEST RAP
STAR NOW CALLING OUT COMMUNIST
CHINA.
KANYE WEST TERMINATING THE DEAL
BETWEEN HIS FASHION BRAND JEEZY
AND GAP AFTER TWO YEAR
RELATIONSHIP.
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH GAP HAD
UPS AND DOWNS BEFORE THE BIG
BREAKUP YOU MAY RECALL THE
BACKLASH KANYE DEMANDING HIS
JEEZY GAP CLOTHES BE SOLD OUT OF
CONSTRUCTION BAGS.
NOW HE SAYS THEY'RE BREAKING IT
BY NOT OPENING RETAIL STORES AND
IT GOES DEEPER THAN THAT AND
INVOLVES CHINA.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THEY HAVE A LOT OF
COMMITMENTS TO CHINA AND, YOU
KNOW, WHEN WE WANTED TO DO
LOCALIZED MANUFACTURING, WHICH
IS COMPLETELY POSSIBLE WITH SOME
OF THE FACTORIES THAT I'M BUYING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, WE CAN
ACTUALLY BRING INDUSTRY BACK TO
AMERICA.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT, YOU KNOW,
I'M THE LEADER.
I'M THE KING, RIGHT?
SO A KING CAN'T LIVE IN SOMEONE
ELSE'S CASTLE.
A KING HAS TO MAKE HIS OWN
CASTLE
>> Geraldo: OKAY, YE, TYRUS, YOU
HAVE A SITUATION HERE WHERE THIS
GUY IS CLEARLY VERY, VERY
CREATIVE.
24 GRAMMYS, HE CAME UP WITH THAT
CONSTRUCTION BAG IDEA.
I NOTICED IT.
YOU KNOW, HE'S VERY, HE'S LIKE A
NONSTOP CREATIVE MACHINE.
ISN'T THIS -- CAN HE BE RIGHT?
>> Tyrus: YEAH, HE'S CRAZY LIKE
A FOX AND JUDGE, HE ANTI NO, YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> Judge Jeanine: DON'T GO
THERE.
>> Tyrus: HE'S WILLING TO DO
WHAT APPLE WOULDN'T DO, WHAT THE
NBA WOULDN'T DO, WHAT OUR WHITE
HOUSE WOULDN'T DO.
HE TOOK A STAND AGAINST CHINA.
YOU'RE MANUFACTURING IN CHINA,
I'M OUT.
AND NOT ONLY THAT, HE'S WILLING
TO INVEST HIS OWN MONEY IN,
WHERE?
WHERE'S THAT PLACE WE ALL USED
TO TALK ABOUT?
OH, AMERICA.
HE'S GOING TO BUILD FACTORIES
>> Joey: WELL, CALIFORNIA.
>> Tyrus: IT'S STILL OURS AND
BRING HIM A CUP OF WATER.
BUT IT'S PHENOMENAL WHAT HE'S
DOING AND OF COURSE THE CRITICS
ARE GOING TO SAY HE'S CRAZY BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF THAT'S CRAZY SIGN ME UP I'LL
HAVE TWO OF WHAT HE'S DOING.
HATS OFF, THANK YOU SIR
>> Geraldo: KATIE WHAT ABOUT
THAT FACT UNLIKE LeBRON FOR
EXAMPLE TAKING ON CHINA.
>> Katie: CON YAW WEST IS A VERY
SUCCESSFUL DESIGNER, HE'S AN
INDEPENDENT AND FREE MAN AND
WHEN YOU DO BUSINESS WITH CHINA,
IT'S NOT A 2-WAY STREET.
YOU GIVE CHINA A LOT OF POWER
OVER YOUR MARKETING VALUE.
>> LIKE APPLE.
>> Katie: OVER YOUR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY AND KANYE WEST'S
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY IS WHAT HE
THINKS IS THE MOST VALUABLE TO
HIM AND CLEARLY GIVEN HE WANTS
TO BRING JOBS BACK FROM CHINA HE
GETS MORE CONTROL OVER THAT AND
GOOD FOR HIM IF HE WANTS TO OPEN
UP FACTORIES IN CALIFORNIA,
EMPLOY AMERICANS IN THOSE
FACTORIES TO MAKE HIS CLOTHING
AND HAVE MORE CONTROL OVER HIS
BUSINESS.
SO GOOD FOR HIM
>> Geraldo: OR IS HE, JOEY JUST
SPINNING FOR A DEAL THAT'S GONE
BAD?
>> Joey: MY INSTINCT ON THIS IS
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
HE'S PROBABLY A FLAWED MESSENGER
IN THE DEAL WILL GAP HE'S
PROBABLY NOT BLOWING IT UP
BECAUSE OF CHINA BUT AN IDEA TO
BRING AN IDEA POPULAR TO THE
FOREFRONT TO EXCUSE A DEAL
THAT'S GONE BAD IS THEY PROBABLY
ARE DEEPLY TIED WITH SWEAT SHOPS
IN CHINA BECAUSE JUST ABOUT
EVERY MANUFACTURER IS AT THIS
POINT.
WHAT BOTHERS ME, I DON'T CARE
ABOUT KANYE WEST, I DON'T
DISLIKE HIM, I DON'T LIKE HIM.
I DON'T LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT THINK THEY'RE THE MOST
IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
BUT SOMETIMES THOSE PEOPLE
CHANGE THE WORLD AND THAT'S
FINE.
IT'S THE MOM AND POPS.
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE A T-SHIRT
COMPANY YOU CAN BUY A CRICKET
MACHINE, YOU CAN BE CREATIVE BUT
YOU HAVE TO BUY CANVAS, NEXT
LEVEL, YOU HAVE TO BUY THESE
MADE SOMEWHERE ELSE BLANKS
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T AFFORD THE
ONES THAT ARE MADE HERE AND
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD TAKE A
HARD LOOK AT.
THE IDEA YOU'RE GOING TO
MANUFACTURE IN CALIFORNIA IN ALL
PLACES, YOU ARE PUSHING A
SNOWBALL UPHILL IN THE MIDDLE OF
JULY.
YOU CAN GO TO SOME STATES THAT
DON'T REGULATE YOU TO DEATH THAT
DOESN'T COST YOU YOUR ENTIRE
PROFIT TO LITERALLY HAVE THE
POWER TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON AND
PROBABLY CAN FIND MANUFACTURING.
JACK 0 HAS A COMPANY CALLED
ORIGIN WHERE HE'S MAKING ALL
TYPES OF APPAREL MADE IN AMERICA
PEOPLE ARE DOING IT BUT GOING TO
STATES MAKING IT POSSIBLE AND
DOING IT OUT OF PRINCIPLE AND
THE MOM AND POPS SHOULD HAVE
THAT OPTION.
>> Geraldo: DO YOU PAY
ATTENTION?
>> Judge Jeanine: I ABSOLUTELY
DO
>> Geraldo: IF IT'S MADE IN
AMERICA.
>> Judge Jeanine: I'M DEFINITELY
MORE APT TO BUY IT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT'S INTERESTING
IS THERE ARE SOME VERY HIGH
LEVEL FASHION DESIGNERS, VERY
EXPENSIVE DRESSES THAT KATIE AND
I HAVE WORN AND I LOOKED AT THE
LABEL FOR NO REASON OTHER THAN I
WAS JUST LOOKING AT THE ADDRESS,
MADE IN CHINA.
IT BLEW MY MIND.
AND THE PRICES THEY PUT ON IT
ARE UNBELIEVABLE.
SO I SAID THEY'RE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF ME, THEY THINK I'M
STUPID BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE MAKING THIS FOR.
LISTEN, THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
FACT.
IN 2021, THE U.S. IMPORTED MORE
GOODS FROM CHINA THAN FROM ANY
OTHER COUNTRY.
CHINA REPRESENTED 18%, ALMOST
18% OF U.S. TOTAL IMPORTS.
AND, YOU KNOW, KANYE, AND I
DON'T HAVE A POSITION FOR OR
AGAINST OR ANYTHING ELSE.
WHETHER OR NOT HE'S GOT A FLAWED
DEAL, WHETHER OR NOT THEY MET
THEIR CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS, I
DON'T KNOW.
BUT I LIKE WHAT HE SAID.
I LIKE WHAT HE SAID.
HERE'S A GUY WHO'S TALKING ABOUT
AMERICA.
HERE'S A GUY SOUNDS LIKE DONALD
TRUMP I WANT TO BRING IT TO
AMERICA, I'M PROUD OF THAT
>> Geraldo: HIS BIG COMPLAINT IS
THEY WANTED IT TO SELL IT FOR 20
BUCKS AND THEY WERE SELLING THE
SAME THING FOR 200.
TO JOEY'S POINT I WANT TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS NOW THAT HE STARTS
MANUFACTURING IN THE U.S., WILL
IT BE 20 OR WILL IT BE 200.
>> Katie: HIS MAIN ARGUMENT IS
GOING TO DEMOCK RA TIES FASHION